you
removal of the gallbladder called
cholecystectomy is usually performed
when there is evidence of gall stones or
inflammation of the gallbladder symptoms
of gallbladder disease usually
consisting of intermittent right upper
abdominal pain most commonly occur when
gall stones temporarily block one of two
ducts that carry bile from the
gallbladder to the intestine if the
stones do not pass the gallbladder may
become swollen inflamed or infected
which may lead to more severe symptoms
such as nausea vomiting and fever
newer laparoscopic techniques require
only keyhole incisions and the recovery
period is much shorter
before the procedure an intravenous line
will be started and you may be given a
sedative to help you relax laparoscopic
cholecystectomy is done under general
anesthesia which will put you to sleep
for the duration of the operation this
will relax the muscles of the abdominal
wall allowing your surgeon room to work
a breathing tube will be temporarily
inserted through your mouth and into
your throat to help you breathe during
the operation you may also have an aura
gastric tube placed through your mouth
and into your stomach to help drain
fluids produce there most cases take
between 30 and 60 minutes to perform
to gain access to your gallbladder and
surrounding structures your surgeon will
use sharp instruments called trocars to
create a series of small holes or ports
through your abdominal wall one of these
ports is usually located at the navel or
umbilicus carbon dioxide gas is then
pumped through the umbilical port to
puff up your abdomen so its contents can
be viewed more easily next your surgeon
will insert the laparoscope through the
umbilical port images from its camera
are projected onto a video monitor in
the operating room using other
instruments pass through the various
ports your surgeon will grasp the
gallbladder clip off its main artery and
duct drop it into a specimen bag and
remove it through one of the ports
before removing the laparoscope your
surgeon will take one final look around
for areas of bleeding or other damage
when the laparoscope is removed a port
valve is left and placed briefly to
allow all the carbon dioxide to escape
from the abdomen finally the keyhole
incisions are closed with sutures or
staples and covered with bandages
after the surgery your breathing and
oral gastric tubes will be removed and
you will be taken to the recovery area
for monitoring you'll be given pain
medication as needed and will progress
slowly from a liquid to a soft to a
solid diet your intravenous lines will
be removed once your gastrointestinal
system recovers most elective
cholecystectomy patients can leave the
hospital within 24 hours
patients with infected gall bladders may
need to stay one or two more days